i read about you and i do not know how
the [ __ ]
you figure out your day i i don't even
know how you have time for family i mean
like i was watching your the tv show you
do where you'll go out with a celebrity
like i watch the one where jimmy kimmel
and you go to the harlem globetrotters
you work out for the day you measure
your body fat
i don't believe that jimmy kimmel only
has 20 body fat but
hey god bless i assume you're telling
the truth
what i do is i'm i'm good at
prioritizing the time
but because i don't have a lot of it i i
make very strict condensed schedules
so you're referring to the show with the
fit so right now
i have coldest balls i have celebrity
game face those are my three tv
face like appearances that i do so yeah
these things you know you're doing
seasons
and i make a commitment to knock out a
full
season in three weeks two and a half
weeks or three weeks
so you only get three weeks but then
after that three weeks well now i'm
going into my movie production and that
movie production is gonna take me
three months to film now after that
three months of filming i'm gonna shut
down
three weeks and that's nothing that's
family that's chill i don't do anything
i come out of that
now i'm gonna take another two and a
half weeks knock out a season to call
this balls
that season is done it's in a can now i
come out of that all right i'm done with
that
next movie that next movie takes me
about another two and a half three
months
shut down for three weeks after after
i'm done that okay guys i gotta figure
out
this next season i'm about to start my
talk show but in between
all of that i've weaved in radio so
tuesdays and thursdays i know i gotta do
two hour blocks of radio each day
so that radio either happens at the top
top top of my morning or at the end and
end of the day depending on my energy
so i'm either kicking it off with radio
after i work out or i'm finishing a day
of work with radio
i put those in the can so my schedule is
intense it's strict
but there is no room for error there is
no wiggle room
because once i put it in it's locked in
and that's what we stay true to
let me tell you something you've made
yes you've made me feel horrible today
uh i'm a lazy [ __ ] compared to
you i mean i mean
good what's on your schedule you want to
know what's on my schedule
i'm beating off from noon to two i mean
it's unbelievable
you